we teach that the story of America the
story of the West it's a story of
tyranny and oppression when in reality
the story of the West is this amazing
story of overcoming those things over
here with jonah goldberg and i can't
wait to jump into our conversation with
joan about his brand new book the
suicide of the West which is a fantastic
read and everybody should buy but first
I'm gonna sell you something else so
we're never gonna agree on everything
but I think we can all agree that we can
use more sleep and getting a great
night's sleep is easier and more
affordable than you think you don't need
a new expensive mattress sleeping pills
you just need to change your sheets
which is why I should check out bull and
branch everything bull and branch makes
the bedding the blankets all made from
pure 100% organic cotton which means
starts out supersoft gets even softer
over time you buy directly from them so
you're essentially paying wholesale
prices luxury sheets can cost up to a
thousand bucks in the store but bull and
branch sheets those are only a couple of
hundred bucks everybody who tries Boleyn
branch sheets loves them that's why they
have thousands of five-star reviews it's
why we in the Shapiro household use bull
and branch sheets we got rid of all of
our other sheets there are that good and
Forbes Wall Street Journal Fast Company
everybody's talking about bull and
branch even three u.s. presidents
they'll remain unnamed but they may
include a president who cheated on his
wife a lot sleep on bull and branch
sheets shipping is free and you can try
them for 30 nights if you don't love
them send them back for a refund but I
doubt that you'll want to send them back
there's no risk there's no reason not to
give them a try to get you started right
now my listeners get 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets at Poland branch
comm promo code Ben gasps because we
have a guest go to Beau and branch calm
today for 50 bucks off your first set of
sheets
that's bol el and branch comm promo code
Ben guest again Boleyn branch comm promo
code then guest okay so welcome to the
show obviously you are a second
important sort advertisers but we're
still first in our hearts I understand
that I was great listening to you at one
and a half speed it was really crappy so
that's it so let's jump into let start
with you Brooke then we'll get her like
the everyday politics senator Trump and
all of that which is I'm sure the rank
punditry that everyone will enjoy but I
want to start with by talking about your
best-selling book obviously you're
you've been on The Times bestseller here
for a while and the the book itself is
an exploration into enlightenment ideals
why we got here and why we are falling
off so let's start with the easy
question why are we falling off this is
the one that seems to be the most
puzzling to
it's like you talk in the book about we
are falling off we're falling back into
tribalism that the enlightenment is a
miracle that happens you call it the
miracle in the book but why do you think
people are disowning it why aren't we
appreciating the stuff around us right
so one caveat I like the Enlightenment
you know what has two thumbs and lexing
light went this guy right but I don't do
what Steven Pinker does and just say the
Enlightenment was this one thing I sort
of taking a page from Mike Meyers and so
I married an axe murderer when it comes
to enlightenment if it's not Scottish
it's crap okay so the French enlightened
is not my bag we there's some good guys
in the French enlightenment but it's not
my back I think one of the reasons why
we're falling off is essentially we
teach in gratitude right so I close the
book with this big call for gratitude
because this miracle which is sort of
Liberal Democratic capitalism the rule
of law it's not just sort of the
Enlightenment or the free-market at all
it's what you know what Cooper Gooding
jr. would call in in Jerry Maguire at
the kuan right it's the whole package
right rather than be grateful for this
unbelievable miracle that pulled us out
of the muck of human history you know
for 250,000 300,000 years man's natural
environment was grinding poverty
punctuated by an early death either from
some boughs doing disease or violence
right and then once and only once
because there's some weird crap that
happens in England we start coming out
of it and to me that's like the goose
that lays the golden egg right it's a
mystery we still don't really know why
it happened there are lots of good
theories when I guess we're gonna argue
about some of them but at the end of the
day there's no consensus on why it
happened and to me I think that's a
useful thing because as as Hayek or
Schumpeter would say capitalism depends
on values it cannot create once lost and
cannot restore either so the the trick
is is to say to say here comes this
Golden Goose it comes into our lives it
lifts us out of poverty it extends our
lives and for the first time in human
history the average human being lives on
more than $3 a day you know if I had a
golden goose I'd build a fence around it
I give it good food I'd take care of it
what can I get you today mr. goose right
and instead we have a policy and a
cultural policy a suicidal policy from
all the commanding heights of the
culture to teach people to be ungrateful
right the opposite of gratitude is
entitlement and resent
and the store we teach that the story of
America the story of the West it's a
story of tyranny and oppression and
cruelty and bigotry when in reality the
story of the West is this amazing story
of overcoming those things every
civilization in all of human history
since the Agricultural Revolution had
slavery slavery is not what defines
Western civilization the fact that we
ended it is one of the things that
defines Western civilization so I want
to teach about things like slavery but I
want to teach them so we can tell people
the good story about how we got rid of
it not that we had it and and instead
what you get from the sort of Howard
Zinn crowd from the identity politics
crowd are these arguments that basically
say that it's not it used to be that our
party used me the argument was working
for criticals right that we're not
living up to our standards I'm totally
open to that right that's that was the
moral grandeur of Martin Luther King's
March on Washington speech was saying
you guys aren't living up to the best
story you tell about yourself or your
ideals right right no problem with those
kinds of indictments I mean I might
disagree on the specifics but as a
principle on the bar now the argument of
free speech on campus about all sorts of
once considered sort of ideals about
individuality about merit those ideals
themselves are now being taught as being
inherently suspect or oppressive or
cruel or bigoted and that is a suicidal
choice I think there are other things
about on capitalism capitalism doesn't
just simply destroy bad customs it also
is relentlessly corrosive to good ones
and so it takes work and upkeep to
maintain the family to maintain
institutions to maintain religious
organizations and religious commitments
because the relentless rationalism of
the marketplace unless it is is sort of
tempered and held at bay by other
cultural norms can have negative
consequences as well so that so that's
what is happening but why why was it
that from the 1950s and on basically
especially the United States has decided
that all of these old things need to be
put away and capitalism needs to be
assaulted where is that coming from so
there are theories about the Frankfurt
School they're theories about the
decline of religion America if you had
to kind of create a description for what
was the mindset that led to this
rejection of the golden goose right
where where did that come from because
the truth is that your book really
should be called the
of the West not the suicide of the West
the best majority of it is about how we
got out of the muck in the first place
that's true it's really only the very
end you start talking about you know the
end gratitude but I guess I'm asking a
different question which is where is the
ingratitude springing from okay so I'm
not happen I would make the argument
which is controversial in some places
that so I've sort of had a reawakening
or rethinking about my understanding and
my view towards ideology generally I
still love intellectual history I still
think I really like arguing about these
subtle distinctions but at the end of
the day I've come to believe that
basically almost all forms of
collectivism socialism you know the cult
of unity moral equivalent of war or
whatever whatever labels fascism want to
put on these things these are basically
different trade names for the same
impulse which is this sort of tribal
desire to get all your meaning from
their group they're super showy in
general will and and so since I bring up
or so I'll say I think that whether it's
the Frankfurt School or or some other
sort of left-wing identity politics I
think the the the original cause of our
problems stem from essentially
romanticism romanticism is this subject
that no one wants to revisit because
we've we have bad memories of reading
poets we didn't understand or something
like that or not understanding paintings
whatever that's fine
my understanding of romanticism is that
basically it is the argument that your
own personal feelings your emotions
remember emotions and feelings are just
synonyms for your instincts basically
right for your gut that these are the
highest sources of truth these are the
highest sources of authenticity and
because part of my argument is that
capitalism and democracy and the market
are fundamentally unnatural phenomenon
this is that romanticism is really just
your inner primitive screaming in your
ear saying the world shouldn't be like
this and it takes on different forms in
different places like Sanders is wise
presumably it sometimes it's Bernie
Sanders I mean it takes on it takes on
all sorts of fascinating different
voices is but it is this whispering
thing that says the inner lamp of your
own feelings is what should illuminate
the world and we hear so much of the
stuff about you know you know from it's
all over pop culture I mean animism
informs rock'n'roll in the form Star
Wars movies and forms all these kinds of
things are you trust your feelings Luke
right it's all this kind of stuff
where any notions of external Authority
traditional Authority are suspect and
that is a story that begins basically
with the second the Enlightenment and
peer is basically there is this counter
reaction to it called romanticism and
these two have been at war for all time
they've been at war it is an inherent
tension within Western civilization
within the Enlightenment based
democracies that is this conflict
between self discipline and self
expression you can put a thousand
different labels on it and I think a lot
of our problems stem from the fact that
in this you know this eternal battle
between Locke and Rousseau Rousseau has
been winning for a long time everybody
who controls the commanding heights of
the culture from academia to Hollywood
to music is basically one extent or
another in on team Rousseau rather than
team walked so when it comes to that
conflict in Locke and Rousseau there's a
third character just historically
speaking who is very informative that
was Voltaire sort of halfway between the
two of them and one of the the critiques
that I have of the sort of binary
distinction between Locke and Rousseau
is that the French Revolution was to
paint this as a mere division between
French Revolution politics and and
British enlightenment misses the fact
that the French Revolution considered
itself also based on reason so it wasn't
a pure expression of Romanticism alone
Voltaire considered himself the the king
of reason as I'm sure there was a cult
of reason in revolutionary France is one
of my big problems with Steven Pinker's
book is that he goes 450 pages talking
about the Enlightenment and never
mentions the French Revolution or any of
the philosophy basically he does this
thing where if it's an Enlightenment
philosopher that he doesn't like it
becomes a counter enlightenment
philosophy and I guess the question I'm
asking is are you doing some of that
with romanticism are we are we saying
everyone I don't like is like Rousseau
in this romantic category or is there
some crossover there because the truth
is that Marx has one foot in rationality
and one foot and romanticism and it
seems like there's a little bit more of
blurring of lines then yeah so that's a
great question I'm trying to finally get
a substantive question on this it's
three weeks on the book tour so I am I
actually came out of working on this
book liking Rousseau a lot more it was a
horrible human being right I mean just
horrible human being
but
much more interesting much more
thoughtful than I had sort of give him
credit even though I'd read a bunch of
Rousseau before part again part of my
Armand is again I don't think
intellectual history works I use Locke
and Rousseau as symbols or stand-ins for
two impulses right these impulses where
impulses run straight through the human
heart we're all a little Lockean we all
want to be recognized as individuals and
make our own unique contributions to the
world that were special that if we were
gone the world would miss us right
that's a very lucky and kind of thing
but we also want to be part of a group
we want to get derive some of our
meaning from being part of a cause
that's larger than ourselves we want to
derive some meaning for our
contributions to a some collective
endeavor neither of those things are
evil right and so part of my argument is
that there that human nature is not
inherently evil or good human nature is
human nature is the one eternal constant
what is what is good or bad are the
institutions and morals and customs that
we create that Channel human nature
towards productive ends so there's
something very Rousseau about being a
believing you know Orthodox Jew is part
of a larger community no criticism of
that whatsoever what I have a problem
with is when you take that sort of
Rousseau nyun religious spirit that
affiliation 'el spirit and you try to
get out of politics what you would is
only rightly reserved from religion
right and said that would bring me to my
my point about the French
revolutionaries I agree with you that
they they believed that they were
invoking reason but I think that the
second you start talking about the cult
of reason and you declare the the
Cathedral of Notre Dom will now be the
temple of Reason and we're gonna start
over at year zero there's something else
going on and so with the the the and
remember all these guys were deeply
influenced by Rousseau I mean they think
they disinterred him and they marched
his body through and ribéry that's right
I mean they basically I mean they
treated him the way the Iranians treated
the body of the Ayatollah Khomeini and
they really were nuts about him and and
so one of the key differences I would
argue between the sort of Scottish
British Enlightenment and the French
enlightenment is that the the French
enlightenment sought to make Reason a a
replacement for religion and Robespierre
and these guys were very honest about
how they were trying to cultivate the
religious
they're also very intense nationalists
and they wanted to create this sort of
the idea that the French were the new
Jews the new chosen nation and all that
and and so I think part of the problem
and this is something that I think it's
fascinating is that Rousseau picked up
on this better than almost anybody else
he recognized that the French feel Asaf
we're behaving like the priests of the
Catholic Church had in the ansan regime
they were committing the sin of what an
English philosopher Harrington calls
priests Rast
sort of like the ancient Greek priests
who claimed to have special knowledge
about the innards of birds and could
tell you where they are you want to win
a war or whatever right they were using
their guild like power over the minds of
men to manipulate people for their own
benefit and that's what we're so thought
the feel of soft sand in the champions
of reason we're doing what the other
thing that the Jacobins and those guys
believed in which is the borrow a phrase
from social science bat guano crazy
they believed in the perfectibility of
man and that is the big difference I
think between the English between the
two Enlightenment's right and I talked
about this a little bit in the book one
of the great sort of illustrations sort
of like this Locke versus Rousseau thing
between the two different cultures is
and you've olive in gets a lot of this
in his book on Thomas Paine and Burke
the the French gardens of Versailles
right the typical Enlightenment French
gardens are always crazy corkscrew
carved you know bushes where linear
angles that can't be found in nature and
all those kind of stuff and the English
gut and the english conception of a
garden was just simply this zone of
freedom where the inhabitants of the
garden could either best sell right so
if you as you all likes to point out in
burke almost all the metaphors in the
language are about space giving people
space to pursue happiness as they see it
giving people space to fulfill
themselves all the language from pain
and or from the the french was towards
was was a direction we're heading
towards a promised land we're heading
towards a utopia and that's why i think
that i think there's that tension you
know and that tension comes up that
story comes up over and over again in
western civilization of those who
believe in the prefect
man because we believe in the
perfectibility of man you also believe
in the perfectibility of society because
you can't get one without the other and
those who sort of take like the founding
father is that human nature as a
constant and the best you can hope for
is a good society not a perfect society
and I can't remember how we got here
that's I think that'll do for now yeah
so I'm gonna ask you in just a second
about the role of religion in all of
this because I know some of the
criticism of your book including some
for me has been about going back further
than the Enlightenment and the roots of
that but before we get to that first I
want to say thanks to our sponsors over
at Anu Chino
every dude looks better in a suit and
endo Chino is the world's largest
made-to-measure menswear company they've
been featured in major publications
including GQ Forbes Fast Company they
make suits and shirts made to your exact
measurements for a great fit dudes love
the wide selection of high quality
fabrics the options to personalize all
the details including your lapel lining
monogram so here's how it works
visit a showroom where you shop online
at endo Chino comm you can pick their
fabric you can choose your
customizations you can submit your
measurements and then you just wait for
that custom suit to arrive in a few
weeks I did this over in Beverly Hills
it's really a great process it's really
enjoyable and you get a really nice suit
on the other end this week my listeners
can get any premium Enzo Chino suit for
just 379 bucks at Indo Chino calm when
you enter been guest at checkout that's
50% off the regular price were made to
measure Premium suit plus shipping is
free
that's Indo Chino com promo code been
guests because I have a guest for any
premium suit for just 379 bucks and free
shipping incredible deal for a suit
they'll fit you better than anything off
the rack ever could go check it out it's
Indo Chino calm and our promo code is
been guest ok so back to deeper topic so
the so one of the distinctions that I
that I would make between the French
Revolution and the English enlightenment
revolution is that a lot of the
Enlightenment thinkers putting aside for
a David Hume for a moment a lot of the
Enlightenment thinkers were still
ensconced in this in a certain level of
respect for judeo-christian tradition
writers what Burke talks about in his
rejection of the French Revolution is
this idea that we are that the
Enlightenment revolution in Britain was
based on the idea of respect for a
certain level of custom or as the French
Revolution comes in and they just say
everything is getting overturned it was
specifically designed to strangle the
last the what does it strangle the last
King what they got to the last priest
yes I'm Caroline Volterra line so it's
that means that the rejection the are we
going too far in prising reason is the
only value without enough respect to
custom because I think that one of the
things that may have happened in in the
latter half of 20th century is exactly
that that on the one hand you have this
wild romanticism that you talk about and
on the other hand you have a materialist
atheism that's arisen that's basically
said we are sentient balls of meat
wandering through the universe and we'll
make our own we'll make our own purpose
somehow despite the fact we have no free
won't we'll make our own purpose and
that this sort of takes the heart out of
human beings that this makes you
ungrateful for the society that you have
that's built on supposedly all these old
awful institutions we have to do away
with right so you know full disclosure I
am NOT an atheist first sentence in the
book is there's no God in this book
because what I am trying to do is
persuade people who disagree with me and
appealing to God is able as the is this
dispositive Authority is a lot everybody
off yeah it's a logical fallacy unless
you already stipulate that God did it
right so so I'm not an atheist I believe
in God I have enormous respect for
religion I am a bad Jew but I but I feel
guilty about it so I think there's over
and and so I'm perfectly happy to pull a
Jeremy Corbyn and say it all starts with
the Jews right but in a positive way
right and so you know my take on it
would be that until Jews come along more
or less gods are our servants rather
than our masters right years akkad for
war was it God for fertility you give
them a bull you sacrifice some pigeons
whatever and they deliver it's
fee-for-service with God's right in
every city state it's got its own God
it's you know whatever that is gonna
publish it exactly yeah and then I'm
it's sort of it's got a burr but for
God's Way and then the Jews come along
and they say no not man you guys have
got it completely wrong gods don't work
first of all there's only one of them
and he doesn't work for you you work for
him right and he's watching you all the
time all of the time which is a huge
bummer
right and and and a lot of things flow
from this including the sort of innate
moral dignity of the individual
including for the first time in ancient
societies women right but it's still
basically the
rival things just for the Jews really
because there's a in hostile territory
and then Christianity comes along this
is a sociological argument but
Christianity comes on and universalize
is these Jewish precepts and says no no
everybody is worthy of dignity
everybody is worthy of respect the
golden rule is pretty you know important
Christianity also comes along and
creates this vitally important thing for
the emergence of capitalism and
democracy which is a social space where
religion isn't dispositive of every
question right so this indian city of
god versus city of man right right so it
starts with jesus saying
render unto caesar what is caesar's
right and then you have Saint Agustin
and a lot of people don't seem to know
that the city got in city man aren't
places they're states of mind right and
so there's some people who are just good
Christians and but they're gonna live
amongst people who aren't just simply
for almost pragmatic terms st. Augustine
argues you got to figure out a way for
these people to live together without
killing each other because ultimately
God is the only person who knows who
saved and it was not right and that
creates social space fast-forward to the
you know the religious wars of Europe
the Treaty of Westphalia was not a no
one was says no one said oh we fought
these religious wars for 100 years
because we think there's this wonderful
principle of religious tolerance they're
like damn it we just can't kill all the
Huguenots I guess we're gonna have to
figure something out and they come in
it's sort of this this it's it's it's
it's tolerance because of martial
exhaustion right and and that's where
concepts like free speech come out their
right to be wrong comes out of this
social space that's created where no one
institution can control everything so
one of the arguments I would make coming
at this from a more secular perspective
on it is yeah I entirely agree with you
that we can even go way too far with the
reason stuff I would I I'm sort of a
Hayekian in my bones which also makes me
sort of a Burkean in my bones I think
that there is more what the heightened
types would call embedded knowledge in
social customs and norms then we can get
our heads around right there are in all
of that all the cliches about how you
know your grandmother was right about
everything well your grandmother's right
because she inherited this vast amount
of trial-and-error wisdom that it
accumulated over centuries or millennia
and you just think about all the
embedded knowledge that goes into
virtually any cuisine you can heat right
I mean how many people died from eating
this poisonous thing or this undercooked
thing or this spoiled that until they
figured out how to cook food you don't
it's like a price signal you don't see
all of the trial and error that goes
into it you just get the end product and
it's very much like Chesterton's fence
you know we we the problem is is that we
are raising people now that we're
raising generations people including
among intellectuals I would say almost
particularly among the intellectuals who
think that just because they can't see
the embedded wisdom and the trial and
error that went into some custom or norm
there must not be any in it man does not
live by bread alone man is a you know as
well as will her burg one of my favorite
intellectuals would put it man should
probably be called homo religio we were
a religious we're we were religious
beings you can make a very strong case
that it was an evolutionary adaptive
adaptation that allowed us to survive
because it breathes out truism and
cooperation and all these kinds of
Harare makes the case it allows you to
expand beyond the one hundred and fifty
person group that's right yeah and and
and I'm open to all those arguments I'm
also open to the transcendent argument
my only point is is that I think it's
somewhere in Plato you know he makes
this point that something can if
something is true it's true for a lot of
reasons right the number of for equal is
4 because 1 plus 1 plus 1 plus 1 is 4
but also because 2 plus 2 is 4 you know
and all that kind of thing you can come
at it from a lot of different places and
one explanation doesn't invalidate other
explanations so it could all be just
God's plan or it could be evolution or
it could be both
but I certainly think that you know a
big argument about big part of my book
is you know khana aren't like to say
every generation Western civilization is
invaded by barbarians we call them
children right and that's basically a
big chunk of the argument of book right
there is this idea that you're not born
into some abstraction you're born into
an actual family and your family is what
civilized you what models good behavior
and what teaches you right from wrong
it's what teaches you how to use a knife
for kits you know it teaches you all the
little stuff and all of the big stuff
and it works on principles that have
nothing to do nothing to do with the
market right I mean I am literally and I
think I suspect you are too you're far
closer to a communist in your own family
right of course because in your own
family it really is from each according
their ability to each according to their
new yeah you don't you don't you don't
charge your kids for food yet right you
don't charge rent yet I may behave if
they behave right you know I give my kid
rain or shine when I have to leave town
I handcuffed her to the radiator and I
give her a bowl of kibble where she's
been good or bad I'm that good of dad
right and no but my point is is that the
values of what Hayek will call the
microcosm are not based on contracts and
rationality they're based on deep
powerful notions of solidarity and
mutual obligation that are much better
expressed and represented by religious
concepts by you know moral concepts not
by rational concepts and so a big part
of my art so Hayek and the fatal conceit
talks about the microcosm and the
macrocosm in the microcosm that's the
world of kin family friends where your
values of reciprocity Trump market
notions right it's the Gemeinschaft
versus the gazelle chef and then the
macrocosm that's what that's the world
where you deal with strangers yes and
one of the beautiful things about
capitalism is it turns strangers into
exes step from existential enemies into
customers right and so you can't take
the values of the microcosm and impose
them on the macrocosm without destroying
liberty you cannot take the values of
the macrocosm and apply them to the
microcosm without destroying the the
values and moral creating engine that is
the family and civil society and so the
whole point is to keep them separate
keep you know sort of like the Reese's
Peanut Butter Cup commercial you got to
keep the Gemeinschaft out of the
gazelles and and if you can do that
everything works you know if you treat
your family like it's business
enterprise you're gonna destroy your
family if you treat the extended order
of Liberty like it's a family where the
president is our Father you're gonna
destroy Liberty and so you got to keep
these things separate and capitalism is
downstream of the value creating engine
that is
family this is part of my point about
why I say all of the stuff that has
around us is an accident
right I mean one of them of common
explanations for where capitalism comes
from is Max Weber is Protestant ethic
and the spirit of capitalism I think has
a lot of Merit to it right but what I
always want to point out is even whether
it's true or not and I think there you
know the idea that like Protestants
invented savings it's a little iffy for
me right now Venice was was engaged in a
fair bit of commerce right but even if
you take it on its merits or its best
case you know best face forward it's
still an accident right the the
Calvinists and the Puritans they didn't
say if you behave this way you'll will
get rich they said if you behave this
way odds are it's more likely that you
might get into heaven and it turns out
that when you change your internal
habits of the heart and your your your
morals to things like thrift delayed
gratification honest dealings you're
actually going to do better in business
but it wasn't it wasn't the prosperity
gospel right and so the fact is is that
the that capitalism will fail if we
don't civilize the barbarians they're
born into our family to be citizens in
this civilization and I argue that one
of the reasons why we have identity
politics and all these other problems
that are coming up is precisely because
of family breakdown because civil
society is is is eroding I mean people
are retreating into their homes to watch
politics and stuff as an entertainment
rather than finding a tribe that's and a
family yeah they're and these artificial
tribes suck again to borrow from social
science and you know Facebook is fine
for keeping up with your old friends
that you met in the real world it is
horrible for like actually creating a
sense of real community because virtual
communities not community yeah I noticed
that on Twitter that was one of the big
lessons I've learned from quitter it's
not not natural community guys it's
actually more like a mob but and let's
talk about tribalism for a second sure
because there's been this this rich
debate you and I are actually on one
side of debate and I know that rich
Lowry and some others have been on the
other side of the debate the nationalism
versus patriotism debate yeah and I want
to delve into that in just a second but
first I want to say thanks our sponsors
over at man crate so here is the problem
with Father's Day dad is not gonna tell
you what to get him truth is he doesn't
know what he wants but this Father's Day
you can give him a gift
he's guaranteed to love with man crates
these are hand-picked packaged gift
for every type of dad if the knife
making kit for the hands-on dad the axe
murderer or the whiskey appreciation
crate for fathers who like the finer
things most gifts ship in a sealed
wooden crate with a crowbar so he
actually gets to pry open the man crate
with his own manly hands in front of
everyone
when's the last time you gave your dad a
gift you needed a crowbar to open
probably never
oh man crates you can and it's awesome
you're giving your dad more than a gift
you're giving him a gift experience
unlike any other I have gotten one from
the people at the office I was very
grateful Porter's poker chips it came
out like an ammo can it's really awesome
plus every man crate comes with a 100%
satisfaction guarantee get your special
Father's Day discount today at men
crates calm slash Ben guess because I
have a guest this is a limited time
offer only for Father's Day go go there
today its man crates calm slash been
guest one time man crates calm slash
been guest check it out okay so you know
if you study the ancient Greek you would
know the correct pronunciation of that
is man critique so the nationalism
versus patriotism it gets to some of the
aspects of tribalism that we've talked
about because there is I think it's fair
to say good tribalism is and the
tribalism of ideas and then there's bad
tribalism as in the tribalism of race or
the tribalism of class things that you
can't change about yourself that you are
born into this would be bad tribalism
and tribalism of ideas where you are
part of a group because you identify as
part of this group
these would this would be a tribalism
that is less likely to be a problem
recently I read a book by it's bad gonna
come out in September actually by a um
hezonia over the Herzl Institute and
he's very big proponent of nationalism
and the reason these are proponents of
nationalism and not just patriotism is
he says that there are these set of
customs and histories that play into the
the creation of the tribe and to simply
kind of intellectualize tribalism - well
I agree with you on this list of
propositions therefore we are not part
of the same tribe ignores the fact that
people have a natural inclination to
identify with people who have a similar
history a similar culture a similar
language what do you make of that
argument is there any way to bridge that
particular gap so my standard analogy
about all this is that you know every
poison is determined by the dose right
and so
nationalism is a little bit like salt a
pinch brings the meal together it
combines all the flavors well it brings
out the flavors it really sells the dish
a little too much
it ruins the dish way too much it's
literally toxic and so I'm with Roger
Scruton I haven't read this you know I
don't have the connections you do so I
haven't haven't got any I haven't got a
bootleg copy this book yet but I have
absolutely no problem with the arguments
from people like my colleague rich Lowry
or from from Roger Scruton but a little
nationalism is essential you need some
sort of sense of social solidarity and
cultural affiliation that binds you
together my problem is is that if you
listen to Ryan Salaam or are rich this
this idea of net of a politics of
national unity to me is much more
problematic because when you say that
the highest ideal is not not patriotism
which is basically a creedal idea right
it is like there's a certain set of
propositions that we agree on but is
instead this sort of far more mystic
idea I mean Ryan and rich in your arm
are probably I would think in fairness
not ethno nationalists right they're not
saying that only one ethnicity or true
Americans or true Israelis or any of
that kind of stuff right but nationalism
becomes very difficult to define
particularly in a multi-ethnic society
where there isn't an enormous amount of
consensus around customs and it turns
out that the consensus around the
creedal stuffs not the Kotler weird
cultural stuff and so manufacturing this
sort of national this this concept of
nationalism I think very quickly becomes
exclusionary to a lot of people it will
certainly be seen as exclusionary by a
lot of people but what concerns me more
is getting it's sort of getting back to
this microcosm versus macrocosm stuff
the government in washing or the central
government is the only institution that
has any claim of speaking for the whole
nation and so almost invariably when
political parties who have control of
government take up the mantle of
nationalism it becomes it becomes either
socialism or some other form of statism
and one of the it's sooo weird there's
this vestigial thing from Marxism that
still teaches people that socialism and
nationalism are opposites which is a
fight that
Trotskyites lost in the soviet union
about 1926 they're not opposites they're
far more often the same thing read a
speech by Fidel Castro read a speech by
Hugo Chavez and replace every instance
of the word socialist with nationalist
and everywhere instance of the word
nationalism with socialism it doesn't
change the meaning than any of the
sentences when you nationalize an
industry you're socializing an industry
nationalized health care is socialized
medicine so part of my problem with
nationalism is that if you want to put
teeth on the bones upkeep on the bones
that's not right
you want to put flesh on the bones
that's the cold medicine kicking in if
you want to put flesh on the bones on my
nationalist program the only way to do
it is by having some sort of large
federal and federal government endeavor
so that's part of my problem with it I
also you know it's also just worth
pointing out but that people think the
nationalism is this ancient saying it's
also a product of Romanticism it first
comes out more or less in Germany as a
response to the imposition first by the
French Revolutionary Army and then by
the Napoleonic Army of the Enlightenment
which was seen as a foreign French
import and so these guys like you on
fickt and you and herder creates these
mythical notions of German national
identity as a response to all that and
so ethno-nationalism is is a fairly
modern concept they've always been
countries but this idea of national
nationalism is a fairly recent thing and
it is in its origins inseparable from
ethno-nationalism I think now you have a
sort of you can have a civic nationalism
actually Rousseau is very good on civic
national well he also wants a
totalitarian state with the general will
but one thing at a time you know and so
I just makes me nervous I think the
founding I I very much want to flip the
pyramid I think that I want to send as
much power down the most local level
possible because when you do that only
the issues that really do unite us all
will become federal issues or national
issues right so abortion will probably
rise at the top because it gets the very
question of who's a human being slavery
rose to the top because it's the
question who's a human being but beyond
couple of those kinds of things push
everything else down to the most local
level possible
the founding fathers argued you know in
essentials unity in everything else
Liberty and the AIA don't understand
one's been able to explain to me how a
program of nationalism isn't also a
program of centralizing and federal
government empowerment and I'm open to
arguments but I know any Ramesh has made
one point to me that you know some trade
stuff could be you know like getting out
of the Paris Accords but sort of
populist nationalist but also not
centralizing and so there I'm open to
the possibility that there are more
examples centralization outside the
United States that's right it was a
pullback from the globalists right but
in general I think the internal logic of
a nationalist program that emphasizes
that rather than using a sort of a
background flavor with the pinch of salt
invariably or as a danger of turning of
sliding into sort of top-down government
so one of the things that that's really
fun that we get to do is we get Citroen
intellectualize about the the state of
the conservative movement if there is
one and I want to ask you about that
because there's been so much written in
the past few years particularly since
the rise of President Trump about the
the state of the conservative movement
both you and I were quote-unquote never
Trump errs in the sense that we did not
vote for President Trump I believe that
that we would both consider ourselves
then here's the way I defined ever Trump
it ended the day of the election there's
no more there's no more never Trump
after that because now he's the
president and so he does good stuff and
he does bad stuff and when he does good
stuff yay and where does bad stuff boo
right you have one president at a time
that was my I wrote a column called
never Trump never more where I said I
wasn't gonna start lying about the guy I
was still gonna call balls and strikes
as I see it but he won you only have one
person at a time and so my understand
him never Trump was always a personal
one which was I wasn't gonna vote for
him I wasn't gonna endorsement I didn't
want anyway Congrats so you're in the
sometimes Trump category right and
that's what I so one of the pet peeves
obviously that I think both of us have
experienced is this constant refrain
from some of the bigger Trump fans that
we must be never Trump every time we cap
every time we we criticize him how do
you how do you deal with with that
criticism and do you think it's even
honest at this point I don't think that
there's a lot of honesty to people who
are labeling folks who clearly are not
like never Trump is over they just use
it as it's now being used as an epithet
and the time when the epithet no longer
applies I would say maybe there are a
few people who are legit never Trump er
isn't like maybe Brett Stephens sure I'm
just a woman yeah exactly
David from bad but it's it's we name
them right it's not like a movement
there's no this this weird sort of
notion there's an existential threat
from never Trump pers to take down I
don't see that at all in fact I'm on the
horn with people at the White House I'm
not infrequent basis talking to them
because this doesn't exist anymore like
Trump is the president how do you how do
you deal with this this can ya know like
address a I share your frustration I
think there's a fundamental
it's difficult because some of the
people who I think it's a very lazy
shorthand right and some of the people
who are doing it are friends of mine and
I don't want to like get into I've lost
enough friends in the last two years you
know and so but I think that what
happens is is to give some of them
credit one of the things I think that's
going on is they don't want to name
names either
right and so what they do is they just
use never Trump as this catch-all thing
the problem is when you use never Trump
as a catch-all it very quickly becomes a
straw man and so people and so like
people like you and me
you read what they say and you're like
well wait are they accusing me of this
BS you know I was like well I didn't I
haven't done this but since they're not
naming names and since so many you know
people on Twitter and elsewhere just
sort of refer to me or you or anybody
who's ever criticized Trump is never
Trump they leave it sufficiently
ambiguous that you feel like maybe
they're they're they're taking a shot at
you when maybe they don't have you in
mind right maybe they do have Jen Rubin
in mind and so Part III I think in a lot
of ways it's a lot like the way neocon
started to get used in the first part of
the Bush administration where it it
distorted more than it revealed right
yeah it turned into you're either Jew or
Iraq war supporter right
the new definition or both bagel
snarfing war monger and and and so ya
know look I I it is a it is a it is a
frustrating thing and what happens in in
what bothers me is sort of as a as a
writer is the way people use it as as a
way to score cheap points with all out
pro Trump people by speaking truth to
power while at the in
they're speaking truth to a label that
they don't put any details to so now I'm
gonna ask you a tough question which is
if you can grade President Trump so far
I usually great him along a couple of
lines i grade him on executive policy i
go to my legislative policy and i grade
him on rhetoric because it's very
difficult to give him an overall grade
because he's all over the place in some
places he's he's a hammer hitting a nail
and in some places he's a hammer hitting
a baby so I had how would you grade his
administration so far and then I'll ask
you the the brutal follow-up so first of
all I gotta say that not a big fan of
the moral equivalence between a hammer
hitting a nail and a hammer hitting a
baby yeah but yeah so so I'm not gonna
weasel out of it but I will say up front
there is a raging debate in Washington
about how much of the stuff how much of
the good stuff Trump is done has
happened because of him or in spite of
him right so one of things that drove me
crazy about Steve Bannon and all that
stuff was this constant drumbeat about
how Mitch McConnell was the enemy of
Donald Trump Mitch McConnell has been
the single greatest guarantor guarantor
of Trump's legacy among conservatives
he's the guy who's gotten all of these
federal judges across the finish line
and he I think you know I agree with
Mitch McConnell or everything no but I
think he deserves enormous credit for
that not to be sort of demonized and so
a lot of the stuff like the stuff that
goes on with the EPA the regulatory
stuff FCC stuff that the FDA stuff I
think is great I don't I I think that
basically what Donald Trump has done is
basically says do all the good stuff and
then he just doesn't pay attention I'll
take that anyway yeah you know but there
is this there is this idea out there
that he's actually managing and
governing and paying attention to the
details when in reality one of the sort
of accidental byproducts of the way
Trump came into office is that a lot of
the regular party types wouldn't take
jabs in administration and so the
administration thank goodness went and
got a lot of including a lot of friends
of mine
hardcore movement think-tank true
believers who went in there and said who
knows how long this thing's going to
let's get some stuff done right and so
I'm all in favor of that so so going by
the normal grading process which is that
whatever happens on a president's watch
that president gets credit for on the
domestic regulatory stuff I give him you
know somewhere between a b-plus and an
a-minus
okay and then unformed policy how do you
how do you grade him I think there are a
couple things that only Trump would have
done very few but there are few that are
important right me maybe Ted Cruz would
have moved the embassy to Jerusalem a
name maybe you know but almost none of
the other guys right so the Jerusalem
move pulling out of Paris which I think
was a was not not the big deal people
make it out to be but symbolically was a
big deal well reaching out to the Saudis
and trying to actually broker an
alliance yeah no I think that's right
although again I think you know it may
be more of a byproduct of Obama's
horrible yeah yeah there's a lot of
trumps victories or the product of
Obama's failures right and the Obama so
messed up the the gameboard
that he created these awesome
opportunities for Trump to sort of snap
up so on the foreign policy stuff again
with the caveat that I I don't think all
that much of it as as intentional some
of his biggest fans do still be plus a
month ok so there's so then the here's
the brutal follow-up so I Alaska the
brutal follow-up in one second but first
I'm gonna I'm gonna have to pitch some
life insurance so our friends over at
policy genius make sure that you're
covered in case you died now you're not
thinking you're gonna die I know you're
sitting there and you're thinking listen
I'm just listening to this podcast why
are you bothering me about death well
tough noogies folks you're gonna die and
that means that one day your family will
be left breath if you did not actually
go out and get life insurance almost a
hundred percent of people think buying
life insurance is a pain in the neck
however and they are largely right which
is why policy genius exists it's the
easy way to ensure you can compare life
insurance online in just five minutes
you can compare quotes from the top
insurers to find the best policy for you
policy genius has helped over 4 million
people shop for insurance and placed
over twenty billion dollars in coverage
they don't just make life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
and renter's insurance and health
insurance if you care about it they can
cover it so if you've been thinking
about getting life insurance go to
policy genius.com it's the easy way to
compare the top insurers and find the
best policy for you you'll be saving
time and money and hassle and it's free
checkout policy genius don't leave your
family without money if you plotz
make sure that they're protected life
insurance does not need to be a pain in
the neck go into it policy genius.com
okay so here is the brutal follow-up the
election is today do you vote for
President Trump who's running against
Joe Biden still probably not I don't
vote for Joe Biden either I live in
Washington DC I could I truly couldn't
give really think so so why so why
what's the what's the downside to voting
for President Trump because I would
basically say at this point here was my
view going into the election and again
neither of us voted for President Trump
so we're talking about some weird 2018
special election right right exactly
it's weird 2018 special election nothing
has changed between now and 2020 he's
gone into a basement for life his frozen
it's it's it I did say if I lived in
Ohio in 2016 I would have voted for
Hillary Clinton
I wouldn't vote availa Glen I probably
would have voted for Trump
so it's so the things that I was worried
about with President Trump were
threefold I was worried that he was
going to soulshock the party which seems
to have happened somewhat among elected
officials but does not seem to have
happened among the intelligentsia or
even the people who are necessarily
conservative voters certainly not
concerned young voters who are people
who I deal with on a frequent basis I I
was worried that he was going to turn
that he was going to pursue policies
that were not conservative because he'd
been all over the place obviously and
then he's now governed as a pretty
deeply conservative president even if he
doesn't believe a lot of this stuff and
then there was my third worry which is
still my worry which is that he would
toxify the Republican Party brand for so
long they would actually do serious
damage down the line for young people
my only alleviating concern there is
that the damage may have already been
done so if the damage is already done
then are you really making damage any
worse if he's president for eight years
instead of four here so with that said
if the election were held today against
Joe Biden I wouldn't have much of a
problem pulling the lever for him even
though I live in California my vote
doesn't matter so what exactly is the
the biggest holdup for you and I don't
mean to be a gotcha yeah no no I get it
um you know and I reserve the right to
change my answer later first of all you
know a part of my argument my book is
about the importance of rhetoric right
that that basically this miracle that
happens basically happened because the
way we talk about ourselves to ourselves
about ourselves changed profoundly and I
think as a matter of statesmanship and
rhetoric the way Donald Trump talks
about this country the way Donald Trump
talks about politics the way Donald
Trump talks
opposition I think is more damaging both
as a sort of just shrank pundit rebrand
question but I also think it is sort of
it is it is damaging to our sort of
political health in the long run
also you know I am not convinced yet by
any stretch of imagination that the
trumpet presidency ends well my position
has been from the beginning that you
know character is destiny
and I don't know that and and I think
that at the end of the day the
fundamental thing about Donald Trump is
he's a person of bad character and if
someone could come up with a definition
of good character that was plausible but
Donald Trump could clear I would love to
hear it I have not heard it yet most of
his values are basically sort of
Nietzschean values you know winning
strengths defeating your enemies getting
praise and that stuff really turns me
off so as a Prudential question I don't
know maybe I would vote for Trump in
against Joe Biden in a weird 2018 sort
of election but my stance towards Trump
wouldn't change appreciably anyway as it
is I mean this is then I agree without
is your critique of Trump like the
voting question is is one that we just
have to get off the table because so
many people boil down your view to would
you vote for him or not which is exactly
what happened in 2016 or it didn't
matter they people stop looking at the
criticism in whether it was valid or not
it just turned into you're either a
member of the tribe or you were not a
man but see this is part of my problem
with what's going on and it sort of gets
you're never Trump for questions from
before I keep trying to make this point
that that trumpism should not be looked
at as as a ideological phenomenon it is
a psychological phenomenon and both in
terms of Trump's own brain which you
know he admits he's a guy who works on
instinct he wants to be flexible he
doesn't really care about conservative
stuff his support for conservative
judges is entirely transactional thank
God you know he basically so not look
like you're forcing it out there yes oh
my god you know someone told them you
just got to give the federal society and
Leonard Leo carte blanche to come up
with names and we'll love you for it
great that's fine but this is the same
guy who wanted to put his sister on the
Supreme Court and so what bothers me
about the way the discourse works with
Trump is that for instance any time I
ever praise drum it's it just disappears
like without a ripple right no one cares
no one
you know no no always trump types say
good for you Jonah or anything like that
but I criticize there you go again blah
blah blah blah blah right so there is
this weird hyper tension about anything
critical of Trump and Trump encourages
this because what he cares about most is
praise and so the best example of this
back when Bannon was still in office
because of the white house dress code
you could only have three layers of
clothing and he was talking about
primary Mitch McConnell and all the
establishment of all those kind of stuff
because they weren't supporting the
Trump agenda basically pelted Jeff Flake
and corker from public life right and
tried to do the same to us as they
wanted to do with McConnell Oh
McConnell voted with Trump's agenda and
the Senate like 98% he was Trump's
agenda in the Senate corker was like 90%
flake was like 88% but what offended
people about those guys wasn't their
support their lack of support for public
policy agenda because there wasn't the
lack of support it was that every now
and then when Trump said something bad
or worthy of criticism they said
something and that drove his supporters
crazy who only want to hear praise for
him and meanwhile Rand Paul did more to
undermine Donald Trump's agenda in the
Senate in terms of repealing Obamacare
and a few other things than almost
anybody else like this Jeana hassle
thing but Rand Paul heaps praise and
honour upon Donald Trump and so no one
gets mad at him so when people say look
I just care of it's a transactional
thing I just care about Trump's agenda I
just want him to get things done and yet
they aim all their ire at anybody who
criticizes Trump and not the people who
actually undermine his agenda I think
something else is going on and is it is
psychological thing that bores on cult
of personality some people I think the
motivations are all over the map some
people just don't want to they want
everybody in the pool so that anything
that comes out of the Trump presidency
no one can say I told you so about some
people just don't want to be reminded of
their own hypocrisy you know there are a
whole bunch of people who got very rich
talking about the importance of moral
values and fidelity and marriage and
good character
who now say all of that stuff is prudery
they don't want to be reminded of it I I
get the psychological phenomenon I just
haven't seen a lot of evidence that this
is really about a policy agenda or or
anything like that so one of the things
that I think has happened here is
there's been a conflation between anti
left and conservative people decided
these are both the same thing rush
limbaugh you know is the granddaddy of
so many of us in the conservative
movement who grew up for me I grew up
listening to rush the in in the middle
of last election cycle he shifted the
institute for advanced conservative
studies and renamed it the advanced
Institute of anti left studies MA
actually renamed it and for President
Trump it feels like a lot of the support
for Trump comes from that is that Trump
hits the right people and he's hit by
the right people and therefore whatever
he does is worthy of praise and honor
how do we reassure you know the the
category of conservative falls inside
anti left but not everything anti left
falls inside conservative how do we
wrest control of the anti left movement
away from just being merely anti left
and more toward the classical liberal
enlightenment values there Hughes
thousand suicide of the West no it's a
good question you know urban question
every crystal used to have a similar
distinction he used to say that you know
that he was anti left not anti state and
what he meant by that was he had no
problem with public schools teaching
good conservative moral values but he
had a huge problem if the public schools
were gonna teach absolutely crappy
left-wing values and so for him an
argument for school choice I don't want
to distort his decision but from that
perspective an argument for school
choice was a was because he needed a
corrective to the bad values being
taught not the evil statism of the
government funding public schools right
and I think there's something similar
going on today I think that there's a in
it I think it's a fascinating dye marker
to see who gets upset about this when I
say this because it's happened a few
times now I think one of the things that
has been deeply corrosive and corrupting
on the right has and I'm partly to blame
for it because I was one of the first
authors to really shine a light on Saul
Alinsky in my first book but I was
shining a light on Saul Alinsky to point
out what a bad dude he was right I mean
he literally dedicates his book to Satan
[Laughter]
uh and so and what happened over the
last 10-15 years is a bunch of people
said look how effective Alinsky was in
it says what we gotta do is we gotta
fight like them and and so what happens
is it goes from being sort of the
conservative mindset as you put it to
the anti Left mindset and the problem is
is that when at some point if you argue
that we need to adopt our enemies means
for our own ends it comes very easy as a
fact of human nature to lose sight of
what your ends were in the first place
and the means become self justifying and
so that's why you know so as I put it in
the book so much of her politics this
days these days on the left and the
right is defined by what I call ecstatic
schadenfreude it's just that things are
worth doing solely because we're here's
our delicious right you know I get it as
a joke and I look I've made a nice
living for a long time eating bowls full
of liberal tears and all the rest but
that can't be the only justification
right if it's like you know you talked a
lot more campuses than I do but I you
know probably on 100 campuses last 15
years and you know one of things I
always try to tell young college kids is
just because being at jackass is
politically incorrect is not an argument
for being a jackass yep and and but
that's the kind of confusion you get
when you mistake means for ends you know
and you want to collect liberal tears
because you win arguments you don't want
to collect wouldn't liberal tears just
because you're a cruel jackass and but
if you can confuse the means and ends
all of a sudden everything becomes self
justifying okay so before we take off I
want to ask aside from your book we're
talking about the creation of good
citizens and then the creation of people
who believe in the Enlightenment what
are the what are the three to five other
books that you would have people read to
educate themselves as good citizens who
understand these values properly that's
an interesting question well we'll put
aside the entire Shapiro as well you
should
they don't fit into this book maybe but
not not the ones every oh yeah so uh
Tom souls conflict divisions Friedrich
Hayek's the fatal conceit not because I
think if it his best book but I do think
it's the most accessible book that gets
it a lot of this stuff I would not say
the Road to Serfdom - what else I mean
I'm a big believer in history I like
that you know Deirdre McCloskey was a
big influence of me on all these books
and I like four books but I'm not sure
they get the core of raising good
citizens whatever the best biography of
George Washington is I think would be
pretty useful and then as a follow on to
that rick burke Heiser's book on george
washington's guide to manners and
civility because I think that that stuff
is really really important and again you
know this is this is more of a gotcha
question than the Trump stuff I'm his
wrath ya know and it's just it's off the
top again and then you spend the next
three weeks with that esprit de Scalli a
thing that it's a fairly good reading
list so yeah I saw there's a book I
really love that almost no one has ever
heard of those just reminded of today
because his son thanked me for
mentioning it on Twitter this morning
Arthur
Iker called the decline of American
liberalism it's pretty largely forgotten
but it's a great history about how
charting sort of how liberalism went
from meaning classical liberalism in
America to meaning sort of collectivism
and I think it's a kind of a useful
thing and it's pretty digestible but I I
reserve the right to come up with a
whole new list of books when I think
about it well good news is you're on
Twitter so we can definitely find it
there and you'll tweet it out when you
think of it okay last question for you
so far that's for the people who
listened to the show probably people who
are 14 and up but you're you're a parent
obviously how do you bring up your kids
to appreciate these values well how do
how do you actually convey these values
to two small kids so when I grew up a
lot of it was religiously based it was
the idea of responsibility and you are
responsible for your own actions and
values and have consequences but how
what measures would you take and do you
take and raising your own kids to
believe in this way yeah so you know
this is a tough one for me because you
know I'm fully cognizant of my own
shortfalls in my own my own hypocrisy on
some of these things and I think any
parent one piece of advice I would give
for parents all parents is hypocrisy is
useful for illuminating some of your
shortcomings or some of your ideals and
how you're failing to live up to them
if your biggest concern is being a
hypocrite as a parent you're a crappy
parent because I I'll be very clear
about this my decision tree went awry in
my youth I have I have made mistakes
I've woken up in hotels covered with
blood that wasn't my own there are all
sorts of things that I would not you
know that I have no problem whatsoever
being a hypocrite about and saying don't
do as I did do as I say
right because part of being a parent is
learning some lessons about your life
and trying to like aren't building a
civilization doing this we just you know
what we kept doing we back in the Stone
Age that's right embedded knowledge is
any hugely important thing right trial
and error is a hugely important thing
that's my general advice for parents you
know towards the end of the book you
know as we were talking about before
this you know God kind of sneaks back in
the book and I think that whatever your
views on organized religion are and and
or what denomination or faith you are
there is something truly wonderful and
important that comes with the concept of
being god-fearing in the sense that if
you if you truly believe that God is
watching you right it's a sort of a
Hallmark card thing but it's you know
good character is what you do when no
one else is watching and if if you have
it in your mind but you know God is
watching what you're doing even when
other people aren't I think that is a
great gut check for for kids it's
something I teach my daughter to act as
if you know somebody up there is
watching what you're doing you know and
as as our people would say the rest is
commentary but also a you know just as a
note the importance of understanding
that you know conservatism rightly
understood and liberalism rightly
understood should see politics as a very
small slice of your life and so one of
things I struggle with is you know my
kid comes home I'm sure this happens
with you where it's going out your kids
are young even my kid but um it's almost
really dumb crap you know about you know
and so like one one day my daughter came
back having just covered Woodrow Wilson
and your house yeah ya know it was like
I wrote an entire book about how the
guys kind
fascist I started I started to turn
green and the buttons start popping off
my you know it was like and and I try
not to sort of make my politics her
burden at school but at the same so I
one of things I just try to do there say
hey look this defines my career in my
life but it it's the important stuff is
stuff we do as a family and stuff we do
with dogs stuff you know that kind of
stuff and I think that is an important
thing is so much so many of the problems
we have in our life are that not only is
lifestyle being politicized but our
politics are being life stylized it is
simply a you know there it is it is
almost a fashion choice but a deeply
meaningful fashion choice to people
about how you vote how you think about
politics the words you say and I'd hate
all of that crap and I hate it on the
right and I hate it on the left the
important stuff and life is about faith
family friends experiences
you should live a life one of the things
I try to impress on or is that you know
without getting too deep in the weeds
about death but you know that at the end
of your life you want a eulogy not a
resume and that's the stuff that I try
to a teacher well Jonah Goldberg it
really is an amazing pleasure to have
you on the show through stopping by and
everybody should go out and purchase a
copy of suicide of the West or five and
give them to all these one copy at least
one copy don't respond from a friend buy
it
the suicide less Jonah Goldberg thanks
so much for stopping by
[Music]
the venture Pierrot shows Sunday special
is produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy borin associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens edited by Alex Singaram audio is
mixed by Mike Carr Amina hair and makeup
is by Jess wah Oliveira title credits by
Cynthia and gula the Ben Shapiro shows
Sunday special is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018